The most deadly predator of the sea spent at state conquering and
terrorizing every creature in sight.
This is the megalot Dawn.
It lived millions of years ago,
but let's assume this muster shark was alive today.
And instead of worrying about other creatures in the sea,
this Megalodon, he's now coming for you,
how would the Megalodon hunt you down?
How could your size be your best advantage and
how could you survive this attack?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if you were attacked by a Megalodon
Megal add-ons are a force to be reckoned with estimates.
Show that they grew up to 18 meters long.
This is three times longer than the largest great white shark ever
recorded,
not dimension that their jaw could open up to three and a half
meters wide.
So do you think you stand a chance with this beast? Well,
let's find out
if you happen to find yourself swimming in the ocean and a Megalodon is lurking
about you might actually be okay.
There's a chance that since your so small compared to its other prey,
the Megalodon wouldn't think you're worth eating.
They instead go for the blue whale or a pack of great white sharks for some
real meat.
But just because you're a puny human doesn't mean you'd be safe
from the Megalodon.
After all the Megalodon was so huge and needed so much energy that it
would take any more. So the food, again,
it's estimated that the Megalodon ate nearly 1200
kilograms of food every day.
But instead of having you swim in the middle of the ocean,
let's give you a chance by putting you on a boat.
And even with this newly added equipment, you still run into some issues.
Being on a boat would be much faster, but now you'd be much easier to spot.
And the Megalodon could now use its signature move.
It hunted the majority of its prey by using sneak attacks from below.
And now with you on your boat,
it would naturally be doing the same thing to you with its
34 metric ton body.
It would Ram your boat from underneath flipping and destroying it with your
boat. Completely wrecked. You'd be in the water with the mega Dawn.
Now hungry for your blood.
And speaking of which, if you happen to get a cut during this process,
the Megalodon would be able to spot you with its keen sense of smell.
Just like sharks. When a Megalodon smells,
blood hit aims to kill no amount of people,
noise or anything else threatening the Megalodon would be able to stop its
thirst for blood. Add this point,
your best bet would be to remain calm and start swimming to shore or
another boat.
This is another opportunity where your small size can be used to your advantage,
depending on which ocean you're in. You could hide between coral reefs,
where the Megalodon would be unable to reach you.
And if you made it to shallow waters,
then your chances of survival would be even better since the Megalodon
was so massive. It wouldn't be able to maneuver.
Around the shallow waters, eventually forcing.
It to lose interest in you and retreat.
But realistically, if you were anywhere.
Near this massive beast.
You'd quickly become it's food. I mean, come on. It's the Megalodon,
this thing was one of the deadliest predators of all times.
I wonder if there's anything that could defeat it in a battle to the death,
maybe the Moses sore,
but that sounds like a story for another, whatever.